[拍手]
皆さんりんごが好きですかそれともみかんが好きですか
どっちですか
リングをあなたは
両方料たくさん食べたい皆さんどう治療たくさん食べたいと思ってるんでしょ
例えばですねりんごが好きな人を組む人はですね
喉が渇いていった自動販売機の前に立った時に
リンゴジュースかオレンジジュースか選択肢が無い時に瓶を選ぶと思います
りんご狩りに行くの闇丸がリークの
その時はりんご狩りに行くでしょうねぇ
人はですね知らないうちにどんどんの子好きな方向に近づいていくんですよ
そっち行きたいと思っています
小学校の赤外思い出してください好きな子の隣行きたかったですよねー
そうやってですね自分の進みたい方向もどんどんどんどん自然とそっちに近づいていく
ものなんですね
山かそれとも海かという選択肢があった時に私が通して海の方に舵を切ったか
これからお話ししたいと思います
私の子供の頃小学校の時代に話はさかのぼります
私の故郷は静岡県富士宮市富士山のふもとです
いわゆる里山というところですね自然と人が出会うところ
大和町の境です
で富士山に降った雪や雨は地下水となってですね伏流水となっていた所に湧き出して
とても豊かな自然はあちこちに作り出していました
この芝かもですね湧き水をた具合で流れる川でやがて富士母と合流して
する側に注いでいます
で周りにはこうした豊かな森がたくさんありましてですね
四季折々に様々な変化今です本当に紅葉が綺麗です
そういう自然を子供のころから体験してきました
夏になるぞですね山を駆け回ってこの
クワガタとカブトムシを夢中でつかまえて
先ほど芝かなんかにもムってですねこのカジカや
それから
いい模擬ですねこういうのを捕まえたりして遊びました
まあ生き物が大好きな少年だったんですけれどもそういうことでですねどう動植物に
どんな昆虫がいるのかとかですね
その根治が何を好きなのかっていうのを体感として知ってたんですねですから生き物
っていうのはそれぞれに住み上げで住んでいる者だというふうに思っていました
でこの日本一高い山富士山が見下ろす下には
日本一深い湾駿河湾があります一番深いところで水深に1500メートルもあります
ここに連れてってもらうのはですね子供の頃年に1度だけでした
夏の海水浴に町内でバスをした手で何時間もかけていくんですね
でもですねそこにと驚きました
私が住んでいるかはにはいないような生き物があふれふさんですね
もう本当にびっくりしてですねもう夢中になりました
普通の近所の子供たちは砂浜で海水浴するんですけど私だけはもう
一目散に岩場に入ってですねこういう生き物を観察したりそれがたまにはですねもう
ウニとかそれからヤドカリなんかを家に持って帰ったんですね
何時間もかけて持って帰るんですビニール袋に入って
here till
中でくったくたになってましたからねいいもう1周名峰泳ぎ張ってですね
自分専用の粉水族館ができるんですねそれがとって嬉しかったんです
でもねぇ
次の朝んだとまぁみんな白くなって死んでるんですね
川の生き物も山の生物の回目のアンディ海の生き物を変えないんだろうっていうのが
とても子供の頃から不思議だったんです
でしかもですね海には1箇所にありとあらゆる生物が住んでいる
山田と炭や決して昆虫がいるのにどうしてこの海にはこんな人所にたくさん生き物が
積めるんだろう
それがまた疑問になってですねどんどんどんどん
運営の好奇心が湧いてきました
小学校も同じ生のときです将来何になりたいか作文書きなさい先生に言われてですね
私は海の中を調べたり写真を撮ったりする仕事がしたいというふうに書いたんですね
当時のことですから子どもたちは野球選手になりたい
医者になりたいとかですね
だから女性ですか子さんになりたいとかそんな多かったんですね
でクラスの笑いものだった私をですね先生が助けてくれたんです
アメリカにケネディ大統領がいたケネディが言うには
海の開発というのは宇宙開発よりも何十倍もお金と時間がかかる
だからなかったお前が大きくなったら海の仕事はたくさんあるぞ
そう言ってくれたんですね
このケネディの言葉をですね私は信じました
海の方が難しいんだ
ですぐこれがでした私の背中を後押ししてくれると思います
そしてですね私が高校1な時です
1969年7月僅かにアポロ11号が月にイティ
人類が初めて月の幻経ったんですね
その中継を夢中で見てました
をやっぱりそうだったのかと思ったんですよ何がそうだったかって言うとですね
海の一番深いところまでは一番名東
なかなか10キロの海底に立った人間はいないのにすでに宇宙に人が立ってしまった
やっぱり海のほうが難しいんだというふうに実感したですねこれがですね私が強く海に
舵を切ることにですね
決定的ないポップとだったんです
そして
海の大学に進みましてですね海の基礎を学びました
で仲間たちとですね自然愛好会っていうのを作って全国の海を見てまいりました
と言うとかっこいいですけれども砂浜にお金ないですからね砂マイテント張ってタコ
捕まえたりかに捕まえたりそれを
浜でゆでたりして食べて遊んだんですね
でもその経験がですねとても今に生きているんですというのはそういうことをやること
によって生き物の行動とか活動とかですね
そういう整体パターンをすごくじかにあも得ることができたんですね
たことに何か今でもすごい上手ですよ
どうやってたボトルが教えましょうかそれやるとバトン部
なくなるんで後の懇親会で聞きたい方ぜひ来てください
こっそり教えますか
で就職の海に舵を切りました
当時ですね日本でへ
唯一の水中カラーテレビを持っている会社に就職したんですね
皆さんご存知は今のあの
手でに水中からてダイブにある日と言いますか
ありませんかありますねー
程度日の暮れ小さいですよねそれで素晴らしい綺麗な取れてしまうんですけれども
当時の水中カメラねこんなにおいしかったんですよ
でもこれを使ってですね様々な国の調査をやりました
当時はですねバブル絶頂期にさしかかっていたころでどのお役所もですねその
報告書にビデオを添えることが流行ったんですねそれが評判を呼びまして次々にこうし
たですね
国の調査関係の仕事が舞い込みました
ですが私はその海の知識に加えてですね海を撮影することを海を調査することを会社に
入って学んだんですね
この会社で来ねえな仕事をしました
そしてフリーになってですね海洋ジャーナリストになったんですね
でそれまで世界が口の調査やいろんなことで撮りためていた写真や記録を基にですね
ダイビング雑誌に連載を始めました
毎月8ページあったんですよ
瞬く間にですね
ストックはなくなって言ってですねその方も自分でですねあちくちの題材を求めて
世界中を駆け回りました
ザトウクジラもそうですしですね海鳥やスイッチの珍しい魚
水中遺跡いろんなものを記事にしました
そうした中でですね私が最も心を惹かれたのがこの白鯨です
オーストラリアの西海岸にですね1991年に見つかったんですけれども
山陽線と1回いうしてグルザトウクジラの中に立った糸白鯨がいたんですね世界で
たった一頭です
これはの色素欠落というと前いいですねアルビノと言いますけれどもそれによって全身
真っ白なクジラが現れたんですね
で
この白い鯨をですねもう
撮影して人に紹介したというのは私のまず海洋ジャーナリストとしての役目じゃないか
というふうに思ったんですね
その後です私これ13年間も追い続けることになったんですよ
でもそう
それが生きてですね初めて本を出すことができたんですね
一冊目の方がこのキャプテンマークの世界聞くを白鯨に会う日までという本なんです
けども
これによってですねそれまであまりなじみがなかった海洋ジャーナリストという名前が
市民権を得てですね
私もあちこちに名前が知られるようになったんです
そうしますとですねいろんなテレビの番組の死以来が飛び込みました
これはのイタリアのナポリ湾で水中遺跡の調査をした時のものなんですけれどもこうし
た
ドキュメンタリーのレポーターの仕事ですとか
それから北極海では各国カナダやアメリカのこの記者たちと一緒に40日間もこの船に
乗りましてですね
いろいろ郡調査をしました
今地球温暖化で国境も大変なことになっています
それから南極にも4回行きました
大学の調査船に乗せてもらってですね色んな調査をしましたですねオキアミとかですね
くじだとかいろんなことをしました
そうした中でですね私の好奇心は海洋動物に向いていったんですね
なぜかというとですね子供の頃自分の周りにはいない生物に憧れて海に入ったように
日本に住んでいないような海洋動物に憧れたんですね
そうしたものをいろいろ調査したり撮影したりするようになりました
でもそんな中で疑問に思ったのはですね
崇祖後の上にはいっぱい入っ
腰化やアザラシが言うのにちょっと離れたコーチの実は全くいない
その違いはなんなんだ
答えはね海の中にあったんです
海洋動物がたくさんいる海岸にはその海の中にですね
彼らのご飯ですね餌となる
タコやイカや階下になどをたくさん産んだに養っていける海藻の森があったんです
これはカリフォルニアのジャイアントケルプというですね昆布の仲間の森です
でもそこでまた疑問が起きました
そうした海藻の森がたくさんある一方でですね
改装も全くなくなってしまってこのような不毛人でに覆い尽くされがな動くという数の
クモ一人に覆い尽くされたような海もあったんですね
なんで海藻が消えたのか言葉た疑問です
でも世界中の海は見ている間に答えが分かりました
それは
陸上にある豊かな森なんですね
この顕著なのはオーストラリアのタスマニア島です
太古からの森が手つかずのまま海岸線まで迫っている
そこで人々も暮らしているんですけれども森を大切に自然と共存しながら今も暮らして
いるんですね
とどういうことかというとですね
この森の栄養がそのまま海に注いで様々な生き物たちを育む海を形成できるということ
なんですね
道すらにやりますと例えばフェアリーペンギンです確かですとかですね
珍しい魚たちもたくさん入ります
私はすごく
興奮したのこの wii dc ドラムというですねタツノオトシゴの仲間ですけど長
さ40センチくらいでですね
まあ今日10時台の池ボレーないが格好してますけど
こんな生物ので暮らしていける海があるんですね
それからもう一つ驚いたのはカナダのバンクーバーとです体に司会やにある
バンクーバーとここにはですね
何百年も前からこうした温帯雨林が形成されていまして今もそのまま残っています
そして非常に来入り組んだ
不安があるんですね
でここにはですねたくさん舐め本頼りに振ります
その雨が森の栄養を蓄えて彼はとなって海に入ってですね
海を豊かにしている
その証拠がですねこれです
毎年春3月頃になるとですね
なんと10億匹のニシンが海岸に産卵にを使用します
この白いの分かりますかこれは
ニシンのオスの精子で海が白くなっているんですね
オスが最初に来て精子を巻いたところに雌が来て卵を見つける
そうやって皆さんが食べたこともらうの
ポンプについてもありますよね
あんなのができるわけです子持ち昆布ってですか
もうすごいできます
カス北海道でに信号点が立つほどいた妊娠が生んでいなくなっちゃったのか
なんで
まだバンクーバーではいいのかそれは手付かずの森が陸に残ってるからなんですね
まあそうしてですね世界70家族以上見てきてわかったことは
陸上に豊かな森があれば必ずそのを機には豊かな海があるということなんですね
そうした上で改めて故郷する側を見ていますと駿河湾を豊かにしている
源その一つはですね私の故郷里山から流れている栄養だということがわかったんですね
私は今8年前にですね古里に戻って山から海を伝える海洋ジャーナリストとして活動し
ていますけれどもですねこの子供の頃日使われた自然を見る目生き物を見る目が海洋
ジャーナリストとしても海の中で非常に役に立ったというふうに思っています
皆さんはですね今をいろんなことで悩んでいるかもしれません
もがいいのかみかんがいいのか
ミックス術だっていいですよでもですね
とにかく自分の好きな方向に進んでみることです
笑われたっていいじゃないですかいろんなことをやってみてください
必ずあなたが進むヒントはどこかにあると思います
そしてそれをヒントにですね自分の進むべき道を決めていただきたいと思いますね
りんごがいいの果実香がいいのかミックスジュースがいいのかそれはですね私がある
ヒントから a たように皆さんにも必ずそのヒントが現れると思いますありがとう
ございました
[拍手]